Welcome to a dynamic video
that will showcase the National
Library of  Medicine's efforts
to support seven awardees as
they use new technology
to raise awareness and
disseminate HIV and AIDS
information.
There is roughly a million
people living with HIV in the US
and one in seven of them
don't even know it.
This video reel will capture
the innovative process
each awardee took to spread
awareness about HIV
through prevention and
treatment.
We will show you how each
awardee organization
created and executed their
NLM project
and how it will be used to
connect with their target group
to increase HIV information.
So let's start with awardess in
the Big Apple. New York City.
He threw up his arms to the
ceiling looked up and said
"there is no cure for AIDS
and there never will be."
He said, "I can't take handling
so many young people dying."
"I just cannot take it."
In 1994 at the height of the
AIDS epidemic, POZ Magazine
founded in New York City
was first published.
POZ stands for being
HIV positive.
It was also a time where there
was a lot of death
and a lot of suffering.
So it was a very bad environment
to be tested positive.
Oriol Gutierrez was diagnosed
with HIV in the nineties and
has been a avid reader of the
magazine since its inception.
For years this magazine has been
a resource for him to learn how
to survive with the virus.
I didn't think that I would see
the age of thirty.
He is forty-seven and now is the
Editor-in-Chief of POZ.
The nationwide magazine reaches
over 125,000 people
with each issue and has an
online version POZ dot com
which gets more than five
million page views a month.
POZ covers a wide spectrum of
needs of people living with
and effected by HIV and AIDS.
But when it comes to online
there's also a portion of people
that we still want to engage
with better.
That's certainly people that are
more tech savvy.
Younger people. People that are
at risk for HIV. Who are not
necessarily living with the
virus but need more information.
HIV and AIDS information from
the National Library of Medicine
was the resource that brought
POZ and D'Vinci Interactive,
a nationally recognized
educational and technology
leader together.
D' Vinci Interactive saw POZ's
strong network and suggested
interactive learning to
complement POZ online HIV news.
Interactive learning takes a
topic that is usually text-based
and puts it into a graphical
multimedia format that grabs
the users attention and makes
them become involved and make
key decisions really in the
learning process.
Mason Scuderi is Chief Operating
Officer for D'Vinci.
With content from NLM and POZ,
his team was able to create
interactive modules and
characters at the forefront
of each story.
So we start with the content
that's there. We pair that up
with visual concepts early on
to see to make sure that both
are consistent, and we bring
them together using interactive
animation, sound, and just the
flow through the learning
itself and getting the user
involved in making key
decisions along the way.
The information from AIDSource
and AIDSinfo was vital in
creating each module and its
associated topic like the
aging module which Gutierrez
says has been especially helpful
for him.
From the aging module I think
what I've taken away from it
the best is the idea of self
empowerment.
The idea of seeing people like
myself who are living long term
with the virus and how they've
gotten through the last several
decades.
Feeling that they can talk to
their doctor.
Feeling that they have
information enough to make
treatment decisions.
A partnership that connects
information and technology
together to help more people
hear and see
how to live with HIV.
[music]
When you think of comic books
or graphic novels
what immediately comes to mind?
Batman? Superman?
Well for digital illustrator
Mike Lurry, he sees a tool
to improve somebody's life.
I am the illustrator for
this project and I also
wrote the scripts for this
project which is
an HIV prevention
campaign geared to the
Latino community.
The campaign is called
Amigos y Amantes
and it's being spearheaded
by El Centro.
A non profit organization
that seeks to use interactive
graphic novels.
The novels raise awareness
raise awareness of HIV and AIDS
for Latino MSM in
New York City.
Latinos represent just 17% of
the population, but when it
comes to the new cases of
HIV they represent almost
25% of the cases
in the country.
The entire process starts
with focus groups
held with community
members.
Initial focus groups were really
about message development.
We said these are the key
HIV prevention messages.
This is material that's posted
at the National Library of
Medicine website.
Here's a broad picture of what
we're thnking we're going to do.
It's going to be an online
comic book with voices
and speech bubbles and
sometimes there might be
choice points where the
action will stop
and you'll decide for a
character whether they
should or shouldn't
do something.
Vital input from the community
members coupled with the
National Library of Medicine's
resources kickstart the
scriptwriting and character
development process
with a focus on culturally
relatable content.
They also need information
that is appropriate for them
that comes from their
experiences.
Where the characters actually
look like them. Right?
That they feel identified
with those characters.
A task that was near and dear
to the heart of illustrator
Mike Lurry.
Having several Latino friends
and also living in a Latino
community of Inwood in
Manhattan.
It was very special to me.
Once the art was finished
content development began.
A key focus was to seemingly
integrate NLM health education
into the story.
We came up with what we call
sort of a circle of friends
structure.
So there's one main character
and then these spokes that come
out from him.
So we know that he's
questioning. He's in the city.
He's having sex with men
and with women, but he's also
got a friend who's openly
out and he's got a cousin
whose having problems
in her relationship.
Harnessing the power of
compelling stories to
inspire readers to feel and
think deeply about health issues
that directly affect them.
Nestled between Philadelphia
and Pittsburgh sits the capital
city of Pennsylvania.
Harrisburg.
Beyond having the unique
distinction as the training
center for the Union Army
during the Civil War and the
present location of the
National Civil War Museum.
Harrisburg now serves as
home to a new organization
fighting a new battle,
Black Girl Health.
Black Girl Health is a
digital publishing company.
Our mission is to transform
every day minority women
into healthier individuals.
We focus our efforts on social
media, online commercials, and
community outreach.
In 2015 Black Girl Health
saw great success on Facebook
using articles and creating a
newscast to disseminate NLM
information and resources as
part of the "Pop the Question"
HIV Awareness campaign.
Pop the question is really
just women taking control of
their sexual health.
When you think of pop the
question you probably think of
a man getting down on one knee
knee and asking their partner
to marry them.
but asking that man to go get
tested.
Instead, this is the woman
maybe not getting down on
her knee but asking that
man to go get tested.
Using HIV information from
AIDSource and MedlinePlus,
BGH expanded their "Pop the
Question" campaign in 2016
to another social media
network frequently used by
their target audience,
Instagram.
Social Media assistant Ashley
Manning converted text-based
NLM articles to short format
videos then published those
videos weekly on the BGH
Instagram page
for it's followers.
HIV is definitely a sensitive
topic. It's something that a lot
of people don't feel comfortable
talking about.
There's definitely a huge stigma
around HIV in the
minority community.
So bringing this information
to them on social media through
video it makes them feel
more comfortable sharing it
and talking about it
with others.
To help in the fight to
raise awareness,
BGH recruited help
from social media influencer
Miss Jay D M V.
So how many women
has he been with?
Oh. Heather, Marie and
Tonya.
That's not bad. Three.
And Brittany. And Tonya's
sister. And Mackenzie...
Ladies are you unsure
about your man's HIV status?
If so, it might be time to
pop the question.
Visit Black Girl Health
dot com today
and we'll show you how.
Bringing comedy to a topic
that isn't fun to talk about
really made the content
more engaging.
Capitalizing on the viral
reach of the video
Miss Jay instructed her
following to navigate to
the BGH website where they
could fill out a survey
evaluating their knowledge
of HIV and how to
pop the question.
It opened up a avenue
for us to have a dialogue
about how to pop the question
when to pop the question
and if you have popped
the question correctly.
BGH Staff Assistant Karlise
Cureton played an integral role
in turning our digital
interactions with minority women
into real world actions at
Black Girl Health's second
annual Kickstart health and
wellness expo.
As part of our Pop the Question
campaign, we are here at the
Kickstart women's health expo
and we are offering women
an option to get screened
for HIV.
The increased awareness of NLM's
HIV information on social media
encouraged women to not
only attend the expo
but garnered several
on site testings as well.
Showing once and for all
in the battle for minority
women's health in Harrisburg
allies prove more powerful
than obstacles.
[music]
HIV is a tide the tidewater
region has not been able to turn
Norfolk State University
is helping lead the community
out of the rocky waters
with Project Choice.
Project Choice is an HIV
education and prevention program
so the choice stands for choosig
healthy options in challenging
environments.
The university program has
focused on meeting the health
needs of African-Americans by
using technology to access
information.
I think the mission of this
project is really in line with
the overall mission of
Project Choice.
Which is to not only educate
students and community members
that we engage with but to try
to prevent the spread of HIV.
To disseminate information from
the National Library of Medicine
Engineer student Keturah
Caldwell created an iBook.
We we're able to put the
iBook together through
of course the software
iBooks Author.
Caldwell says multiple widgets
are in the software which
provide the ability to include
interactive media such as
audio and video that the
reader can play.
Some of which are recorded
skits from theater students
at Norfolk State.
You're not afraid or timid
when you speak.
But...what would we say to
our partners exactly?
Like...with my intuition I
can't help but feel as though
all men are up to no good
and are never trying to listen
to what you're doing and
what your're saying.
So i took the role as being
this ideal aggressive woman
who had been sexually harassed,
violated, you name it.
Protect yourself.
Don't neglect yourself.
AIDSinfo and MedlinePlus were
the resources used to bring
context to the scripts.
She became informed with the
PREP the information of HIV
how to go get help and who to
talk to where to go
so on and so forth and
her character changed.
So embedded in the iBook are
questions that they ask
and then it gives you the
right answer to tell you
whether you're right or
wrong.
So that's embedded in several
of the chapters to make sure
that people are understanding
what they're reading.
[sorority crowd clapping
and cheering]
Project Choice realizes the real
test is outside the boundaries
of campus life and in the
community.
Cynthia Burwell is tasked with
taking the iBook
to the churches.
The church helps to reach the
people.
They will be trained on how to
use the iBook for AIDS and HIV
education in their churches.
They will be able to use it
with different groups in their
churches to provide up too
date information.
NLM information that's helping
give a innovative lifeline
to protect the
Tidewater community.
You have just seen how innovatie
projects on the East Coast
are fighting the HIV epidemic
with NLM educational tools.
Community outreach
organizations, colleges,
tech and digital companies
print and online publications
are all playing an integral role
in making a difference.
So now we're going to visit
organization and communities
further west. Starting in the
Windy City Chicago, Illinois.
Where there's an increase of
HIV AIDS related cases
among African-American
men.
At the close of 2015,
more than 24,000 people
were living with HIV in
Chicago, Illinois.
Proactive a local nonprofit
organization
is on the front lines. Training
and equipping community health
workers on how to deal with
the HIV epidemic.
There are actually four
institutions involved.
Two community based
institutions
and two academic
institutions.
One is South Suburban
College and that's out here
and that's a two year
instituiton.
The other is Chicago
State University.
These Step Up students
will eventually become
community health workers
helping residents by
educating them on HIV
prevention and treatment methods
through the use of tablets.
I know that in the future with
the career choice
that I've chosen this is going
to be a great tool for me
because information that I share
will be from a reliable source.
Proactive will train 93 Step Up
students on NLM resources.
This will be part of an
interactive digital lesson plan
and Proactive's interactive
healthcare readiness program.
I thought that I had the
resources that I needed
to talk about HIV
but as I began to go on
this particular website
I learned more and more
and it was more truthful
and accurate information.
The tablets community health
workers learn to navigate
NLM resources on will prove
useful at off site partner
organizations.
Allowing them the opportunity
to meet people where they are
with vital and accurate HIV
prevention and treatment
information.
We have high risk populations
so they are hard to find and
hard to locate.
But our team has really
been able to go in there
and do segmented outreach
and locate those individuals
that are positive.
Increasing numbers of
qualified health care workers
to meet the increasing need
to treat HIV patients.
On any given day one to
two hundred people
pass through the Mexican
Consulate
in Salt Lake City, Utah.
And a good portion of those
people are just waiting.
And there's absolutely nothing
there to do they just sit there
and stare at the wall
pretty much.
So we use that time
with a "promotora"
our community health worker.
And they take full advantage
of it.
Transforming waiting time
into a meaningful
health learning experience.
The biggest way that HIV has
effected our community members
is the fact that it's not
something that we talk about
and it's not something that
we necessarily know about.
Getting pertinent health
information from a familiar face
also makes a big impact on
those served.
[speaking in Spanish]
Information they may have never
come across
due to the language barriers
they face in the US
and the cultural barriers
they face back home.
We invite them into the
Ventanilla de Salud
to get tested.
We do blood pressure, glucose
and BMI testing and at the end
of every person coming in
to getting the testing
we do a one-on-one session
to go over the websites again
to reinforce that these websites
are available to them
to get HIV AIDS info but also
other health related information
Ciriac Alvares
They've connected over 300
people to health resources
with the help of the
National Library of Medicine
including Ciriac Alvarez.
There is one website in
particular
that Alejandra showed me
where you can find
like HIV testing places by like
putting in your zip code
and it's really cool.
From those surveys we've been
able to realize that
the work that our "promotoras"
are doing is valuable and it
works because we see an increase
of knowledge from the before
and after of our community
members when they receive the
workshop and are able to
access their resources.
Assisting yet another person
to their right to
life, liberty, and the pursuit
of healthiness.
of healthine[music]
Time Magazine dubbed
the year 2014 the
Transgender Tipping
Point.
From the red carpet and
the runway
to politics and entertainment,
transgender people
truly were everywhere.
But for many transgender
youth
the notoriety has not created
impactful change in their
daily lives.
Nowhere is that more
apparent
than in the area of
healthcare.
Transgender youth they have
challenges
they have requirements
and they don't know where
to go to get
their questions answered.
They don't know where to go
to get services
that are youth friendly.
With provider's that understand
the needs that are quite unique
for the Transgender community.
Headquartered in the Bay Area
of California.
The mecca of LGBTQ rights.
YTH is the partner of choice
for those in search of new ways
to advance health of youth
and young adults
through technology.
In addition to those health
disparities
youth are also kind of
faced with they're dependent
on their parents.
They don't necessarily have
an income.
So if they come out to their
parents
and they're not receiving
support
I mean where do you go
from there?
And that is why they
developed they2ze.
A mobile app that brings
together all the Bay Area
resources for transgender
spectrum youth.
So the design itself was really
guided by our brainstorming
process and meeting with the
transgender youth community
and our advisory board.
So that sort of kicked off the
design process where we got
feedback from them on what they
would like to see in the app.
When somebody uses the app and
they are searching
for a certain answer
a certain search term
a lot of the resources that end
up coming up
are actually NLM resources.
The app is available in the
Apple or Android app store
and has features that allow
you to find community hangouts
testing sites and doctors
like Doctor Scott Mosser
a internationally renowned
board-certifed plastic surgeon
based in San Francisco.
I think the app is expansive
for trans healthcare resources.
So any individual that's
looking for an HIV doctor
again blood pressure doctor
or a diabetes doctor
for any reason but wants to
make sure that they're
gender inclusive and
understanding of their
potential gender needs
as well
those are the individuals all
who would be using the app.
Giving Bay Area transgender
youth
their moment for a
better life.
You have just seen the
technical processes
each ACIOP awardee took to
disseminate NLM HIV information.
D'Vinci upgraded a conventional
print magazine
with a scenario based e-learning
module
interwoven with resources
from NLM.
El Centro used interactive
graphic novels
to disseminate NLM information.
Black Girl Health used an
influential social media
celebrity to bring minority
women together
to learn about NLM
information resources.
Norfolk State University
developed iBooks
that combined dramatic
arts with NLM information
to engage youth.
Proactive Community Services
engaged students
pursuing health careers
to use tablets to become
proficient
with NLM resources.
Communities United used
the Mexican Consulate
as a technology center
to educate
Spanish speaking immigrants
on NLM resources
and HIV information.
And lastly YTH served
transgender youth
by developing a mobile
phone app
using NLM information
to meet the special needs
of this population
After showing all the
technical approaches
used to disseminate
NLM resources
we hope you see the
awardees
as key stakeholders
that aligned their efforts
to address an ongoing
health crisis.
In addition the National
Library of Medicine
as an emerging leader in
innovative approaches
to raising awareness
around HIV and AIDS.
We'd like to thank NLM
for promoting
cutting edge technology
to support
HIV and AIDS prevention
and treatment information.
As well as supporting each
awardees
creative uses of
NLM's resources.